ليس قطع نقل المسافرين وحده المتضرر من
قرارات الحيطه والحذر من وباء كرتونا عبر
العالم المخاوف شملت امكانيه تاثر امدادات
التجاره العالميه من الصين لتنضاف بدورها
الى ازمه الحرب المستعره في اوكرانيا بعد
رفع القيود البلد الاكبر من حيث عدد
السكان في قلب اشد موجه من الوباء في
العالم ما تسبب في اثاره قلق العديد من
الدول في ظل بيانات غير موثوقه وتقديره
جزئيه وشكوك حول ظهور متحولات جديده
بلدان عديده بما في ذلك الولايات المتحده
واستراليا وكندا وفرنسا واليابان تعتمد
على عدم شفافيه البيانات الصينيه لتبرير
قرارها بفرض اختبارات خلو من الفيروس على
القادم من الصين هذا بالاضافه الى دول
قررت منع الوافدين منها من دخول اراضيها
مثل المغرب
بكين وصفت القيود الدوليه المتزايده على
المسافرين من اراضيها بغير المقبوله وحذرت
من انها قد تتخذوا اجراءات مضاده على اساس
مبدا المعامله بالمثل تحركات تنذر بدايه
اغلاقه جديده شبيهه تماما بالعام 2020 في
ظل انتشار متحور شديد العدوى سمي بيوم
القيامه غير ان دول كثيره لن تغامر
بالاغلاق التام بالنظر الى الكلفه
الاقتصاديه الباهظه للقرار
بلال الوجدان العربيه